i got to ask you this i've yet to ask
you um i heard that with the with the
movie
you did not know
uh any type of martial arts i heard that
martial arts was not in your background
yeah that you had to learn it
for the movie and that you did like 70
80 percent of the stunts that were
involved for the movie i'll be honest
with you okay can i be honest with you
all
right
it's hard to hear you better this is
heart-to-heart that's true that's true
i'm i down i purposefully downplay how
much martial arts i knew okay because i
am afraid of that narrative okay of like
the martial arts guy they cast the
martial arts guy to do the martial arts
he's asian of course
you know i i i want to challenge people
to see me as an artist and the same way
that ryan gosling picked up jazz piano
for la la land that's the way that i
picked up martial arts for this movie it
is not because martial arts is all i do
that's not because martial arts is all
asian people do and that's all they're
good for
and when you see you know when you see
an asian person on screen they better be
doing martial arts not that but this was
a character and and so i did the
training that was necessary i stepped up
and and i mean sure yeah before i mean
of course hell yeah i did martial arts
you know i i i
took the stunt training i was in class i
was doing gymnastics and parkour and
trying to be you know especially when
you're when you're struggling in toronto
ontario canada and trying to make a
living in showbiz you're like booking
one or two television spots a year if
that if that you got maybe one national
commercial by the way the canadian
commercials don't pay the way that the
american ones do right canadian national
commercial will give you like four or
five grand at the end of the day that's
not a good take home i love what you
said though man i love what you said
which is that you know you're you're
there's a there's a wanting goal
right when you talk about breaking down
stereotypes you have to actually be
a a
an action item i love that message and
that's the beauty of this show the beat
of this show is that you can give that
you can speak like that and that people
can see you in a honest a honest setting
uh being being your true self i feel my
heart and i feel your heart i feel i
feel as doing this that's what it is
that's it that's the beauty
[Music]
you